we were in Paris this summer and Virgil
asked me see I kid you not who's your
least favorite player in the NBA who
could you not see yourself playing I
said there's zeroing chance I'm ever
playing with Chris Paul it cannot happen
Virgil he's like I knew You' say it two
days later I get a call from Mike Dunley
and I'm taking off and I'm like Mike
I'mma hit you when I land I'm flying he
like it's a little urgent kind of need
to know like we got a chance to you know
bring in Chris Paul and I was like
listen Chris Paul is is a competitor
Chris Paul is an adult Chris Paul want
to win Chris Paul play the basketball
the right way we can figure it out we
ain't been the best of friends M I said
but we can figure it out I didn't know
what to think I didn't know what to make
of it I did know yo if he my teammate we
going to make it work and we going some
people up Mike I tell you that you know
my wife Jay and she was almost giving me
a pep talk before I left the house she
was like all right now be cool you good
you you good you good